there have been stories about what's
been happening to people who work at the
American Embassy in Moscow the stories
concern radiation first it was said the
Russians were either bugging or jamming
Embassy intelligence equipment and that
they were using microwaves to do that
and that that was getting Embassy people
sick two American Embassy employees in
Moscow may be suffering from cancer of
the lymph gland
and that Ambassador Walter stessel is
suffering from pernicious anemia the
Soviet Union has admitted that some
radiation exists but the government
newspapers vesa dismissed it as ordinary
non-dangerous electromagnetic activity
possibly caused by the embassy there is
no reason to believe that those
microwaves have caused any Illness but
us Personnel are concerned over
published reports that the microwaves
may have caused cancer in a few cases
Soviet technicians say radioactivity
levels in the US Embassy are at better
than safe levels the state department is
considering taking electronic
eavesdropping equipment off the Moscow
Embassy roof so the Russians will stop
using microwaves to try to jam it es
vestia said reports that the radiation
was caused by Russian snooping devices
are an invention with a foul smell
tornadoes last night and today killed
three persons in
[Applause]
Aransas
[Music]
I'm holding here a measuring instrument
and from the readings we can say that
the microwave radiation in this room is
I would say in biblical proportions or
astronomical proportions it's
approximately 1 million billion times
above natural background which we had
just 50 or 100 years ago so the
radiation levels nowadays are enormously
High compared to what cells have been
developed
in
they are not part of the normal universe
that is a completely new type of
radiation the beginning of the
1980s very few were
electrosensitive but uh today it's well
over 10% I think and the trend is
pointing at close to 50% will have one
or the other type type of
sensibility within the next 5 10
years def business how independent are
the international organizations that are
supposed to protect
us
[Music]
a
I don't like to go into town anymore
because the radiation levels are so high
now so H you feel it you feel symptoms I
think most people who become aware of
what this radiation might cause feel the
radiation quite quickly
now
I'm a Swedish investigating journalist
I've written two books on the issue of
mobile phone health
risks my work uh in this issue started
in 2002 in connection with the massive
roll out of 3G in Sweden quite
immediately discovered that the
information from the industry and the
authorities was not true
in fact uh there were already then a lot
of scientific studies showing that this
radiation could be a major health
risk the reason I wanted to investigate
the health effects of electromagnetic
fields actually go back to the
1970s and 80s and at that time in Sweden
there was an introduction on personal
computers and very soon people started
to report skin problems I still continue
trying to investigate the health effects
of various forms of man-made
electromagnetic
fields for instance heart rate
variability when you expose people to
the microwaves what happens then with
the heart rate also we had studies on
the red blood cells and the formations
of clumps in the blood and also to
investigate the functional impairment
called electr hyper sensitivity every
human being is
electrosensitive but the question is
will there also be people that are
Electro hyper sensitive meaning that
they will pick up Fields signals
whatever that the rest of us doesn't
feel and in that way they will act like
the classical canary bird in the coal
mine they will react as biological
sensors to something the rest of the
population so far doesn't react
[Music]
to
for
[Music]
for for
spee fore
foreign spee
fore
[Music]
for
fore
everyone nowadays in all countries all
over the world are 24/7 whole body
irradiated wherever they
are so in that sense the whole biotope
everything living on the planet is a
Jeopardy they were not developed in an
evolution based on
microwaves the natural levels of
microwave radiation here on this planet
are extremely low and suddenly we turn a
knob and start to send out and all these
signals hit your body go through your
body and the question is is it built for
it and of course it's
not these electromagnetic fields and
waves and signals they carry energy and
it's like pouring energy into any kind
of biological system you will have
alterations changes and of course cell
growth for instance and cell growth is
the same as
[Music]
cancer
scientists has also shown that for
instance microwaves can destroy the
bonds in the DNA molecule which is the
basis of your genetic material and such
damages could be the starting point for
instance for a cancer development so
it's very serious
[Music]
data
for
unfortunately for the radio frequency
fields and for the mobile phones we are
in a situation of scientific
uncertainty I'm convinced we need more
research at the moment because everybody
is is a mobile phone users it's children
using it it's elderly using it sick
people using it so we have to be certain
and this uh this demands uh more uh
investigations
International Agency for research on
cancer is a research institution so we
are doing research and trying to
identify the causes of
cancer the World Health Organization is
responsible for for policy so they are
setting our evidence that we find what
causes cancer and what doesn't cause
cancer into recommendations for of
prevention um the international
Commission on non-ionizing radiation
protection this is an independent uh
panel that makes recommendations on
protection guidelines for
electromagnetic fields but they are
independent of both aak and also
[Music]
wh ikip is a the international
Commission of U experts on this kind of
radiation and nnip has a huge power in
this issue because nnip has recommended
the limits that most countries at least
in Europe have adopted and as pointed
out by thems uh they are only technical
they were never meant to be used as any
kind of medical safety or biological
safety it's just a technical measure but
governments and parliaments and so on
have use them as a safety guideline and
they are definitely not and those limits
are based on an old Paradigm from the
American Military in the 50s that
considered that the only effects from
this radiation is are thermal when the
radiation is so high that it can heat uh
tissue
[Music]
I started training in
1960 uh at the Royal Navy's microwave
training school and and it was my
specialism throughout the Royal Navy was
looking at all aspects of microwave
Warfare by the 60s it was mostly
understood some of the experiments done
during the Cold War that the scientists
found that they could
cause severe psychiatric Problems by
changing the P pulse
frequency imagine you are jumping on a
trampoline at your own bounce level and
imagine I weigh 56
Stone and I jump on the trampoline and
bounce at my rhythm you will be forced
to bounce at my
rhythm that is called
entrainment and that is what goes on
when microwaves go into your brain they
change your own brain waves because they
are bigger and heavier now depending on
the pulse frequency and the power can
affect the heart's pulse rat uh how the
eye sees how you hear bad behavior it
can stop their ability to learn how your
brain will
operate all of these can be done and
they can fall
doctors with that microwaves played a
very big part in getting information
during the Cold War it was reported
today that the state department has sent
a doctor to the US Embassy in Moscow to
see if Russian radioactive waves have
caused three people to fall ill if you
be microwaves at the window my talking
vibrates the glass and the microwaves
rebound back and if you pick those up
you can understand what is being said so
the Russians microwaved the American
Embassy to see what Secrets they were
talking about but at the same time as
the microwaves were reflecting so the
Russians could hear they were also going
through and within 18 months they found
that the children had leukemia the women
had breast
cancers some of the men had Cancers and
virtually the whole staff had to be
changed tonight we have the first report
of a death among American Embassy
employees in Moscow who were exposed to
Soviet microwaves a secretary who worked
in the embassy between 1960 and 62
developed a mole on her face that later
became cancerous she died in 1968 what I
realized uh was
that some of the
pulses used by the communications
industry are exactly the same as the
pulses which are used for microwave
Warfare it's not the temperature that is
a problem it's the effects of the
electromagnetic waves on our system on
our cells and the immune system and
everything I've been working in Telecom
area since the start in
1966 and since
1987 I was within different companies in
ericon
when I was working in quality I saw a
graph uh showing increasing rates of
melanoma skin cancer and we saw curves
of increasing failure rates of products
that was a big problem 100 millions of
CRS for
instance
for
six
okay n
comma
foreign
spee foreign
spee
for
okay
foreign
fore
the protection guidelines we have at the
moment would protect you from any risk
that we have established but whether for
example you should recommend unlimited
use by children that's a completely
other issue and I think even without
strong scientific evidence you should
apply Common Sense here and say it's a
technology that we have not fully
understood it's it's a technology that
you hold directly to the body so we need
more work um on this when we talk about
the reproductive system there are number
of studies clearly showing that male
sperm cells are badly affected actually
and that they lose their movement
capacity and their morphology is
destroyed and but the the most important
studies maybe on fertility in the
long-term run where people have looked
on different generations of mice and
seen that in the future after a certain
number of generations the fertility was
more or less completely gone and that is
of course a very serious uh warning
signal and again I'm surprised that no
one is really paying any real attention
to this what we are now risking by
microwaving the planet
we are saying we are prepared to
risk all of the future
generations of the world with genetic
damage for today's profit margin that is
what we're
risking and it's I'm not just talking
people the cells are identical to plants
animals humans
so if you're damaging a human cell you
are automatically damaging the plant
cells the pollinating insects over 200
of them they are all affected every
single thing there are some very
interesting studies from India where
they took mobile phones and put them
near to
beehives and that resulted in that the
bees left they moved
away a bee will normally navigate using
the Earth's magnetic field so what you
have is a be which is being
disorientated and at the same time its
immune system is starting to
collapse if that would be correct then
we just have to stop radiating these
insects I mean that's uh crazy to do
with in that
[Music]
sense only the future will tell
hopefully it will turn out to be safe
but that would mean that thousands of
scientific papers all at the same time
must be wrong and that has never
happened before in
[Music]
history
several long-term
investigations started that have been
going on for years these long-term
studies seems to be just a way to push
the problem in front of
you get time to make as much money as
possible not to have to take decisions
today it's just a question of when we
should start to react in
2009 uh scientists met in Norway uh
because scientists felt that the nnip
guidelines were not sufficient to really
protect health and life and a special
pretty lengthy statement was published
and it was suggested that uh the current
guidelines should be lowered at least 50
to 60,000 times compared to the nnip
guidelines the authorities experts many
of them know these problems but gives
free space for the technology for the
industry to use their
systems at least I suspect that this
group they are doing a job for the
[Music]
industry
Al
IND
AC an admittance that those limits from
nnip has been too high and that there
are health risks below those limits is a
serious threat also to this industry
there are lots of
money that have been invested in this
system thousands of billions of Eur
the consequences too drastically just
forbid for instance mobile phones would
be
[Music]
drastic
bu
spe
[Music]
you lost the
scientists from 14 countries have
reversed those years of
reassurance
for
the classification of a possible
carcinogen is the weakest scientific
evidence we have so um in the future it
with new scientific evidence it can
change in either direction the general
um pattern I would say for such uh
warning signals is that they start at
the low level and then they move upwards
so most likely in a few years time there
will have been more data collected and
we will probably see an um increase in
the importance of these cancer
classifications hopefully I'm wrong
hopefully it will go in the other
direction it will turn out to be without
any risk but I would be a little bit
surprised then the World Health
Organization changed the cancer
classification mostly due to studies
showing increased risk of brain tumors
from mobile telephone use uh those
studies were made by L Adel from the
euru University in
Sweden and also the interphone study the
World Health Organization 13 country
study that also showed increased risk
for brain tumors of mobile
phones I think that this
radiation clearly merited a higher
classification because there are a lot
of evidence showing
cancer risk from this radiation the
problem is that the mobile phone
industry has dominated the cancer
research from this radiation so much we
have to make sure that that the industry
and the research is clearly separated
and uh of course I also think that uh
the industry has a responsibility uh to
support the research because they make
all the profit from the technology so so
they should be interested also in
demonstrating that the technology is
safe and what we usually do in practice
that we have a firewall between the
funding and the research so that there's
no direct link by contracts between the
researchers and the industry and that is
a mechanism that uh has shown to to work
very well and that is all very well if
if uh they had been independent but
uh the problem is the connections
between industry and these expert groups
and album is uh considered to be one of
the world's leading experts in the this
field and he's a professor at the
Kolinski Institute and he has led all
Swedish export
investigations uh into this
issue he has also been an expert to the
World Health Organization and he was
part of the ikip expert group that
recommended the today's obsolete limits
for mobile
telep I think that the
conclusions uh drawn by and Sh boom H
went through a major change because
earlier he was more careful about what
he said he didn't clearly dismiss the
risks as he does
today and uh
that is very strange so there's been a
major change and I think uh it is those
conflicts of interest that he has that
can explain why he dismisses the risks
that he has clearly observed
himself then I started to to to search
further and I then discovered that his
brother gunar album had for many years
been
a lobbyist for the major Swedish mobile
phone operator telia son in Brussels
while and Alum at the same time was a
so-called independent expert for many
authorities in Sweden and also for the
European
commission well the article about the
conflict of interest of andalum led to
his uh nonparticipation in this expert
evaluation of the cancer risks and uh
after after that the mobile phone
radiation was classified as possibly
carcinogenic which probably would have
not have been the case if and album
would have been on this expert
group
[Music]
for
and it turns out that if you read a
study anyone on random that say that
these techniques are safe H they are
approximately four times more often
financed by the industry as compared to
studies saying there is a health effect
which I think is very very sad in the
sense that already when they were
started they had lost a lot of their
credibility a couple of months after the
cancer classification at the
international Agency for research on
cancer and shom's colleague Maria fing
at The karolinska Institute presented a
study was claimed to be the first study
on mobile phone use and brain Chum risk
for
children it is the follow study and it's
a study designed that we call a case
control study that was conducted in four
countries Denmark Sweden Norway and
Switzerland the interone study did not
include any children or young people and
uh this is because uh the study has
started in the late '90s and uh it was
very few children that used mobile
phones at uh that
time Maria fing claimed in the press
release that the study's result were
reassuring but when you look into the
study and the published results you see
continuously increased risk for brain
tumor for children who had had a mobile
phone subscription for the longest
period when you come to table
four you see here clearly that children
who had used a mobile phone who had had
a subscription for more than 2.8 years
they had uh more than doubled increased
risk of brain tumor furthermore when you
take a closer look at this study you
also see that they present result on use
of cordless phones when we started to
study children the cordless phones have
become much more common a lot of private
households had a cordless phone so the
exposure from the cordless phone also
becomes relevant but they don't disclose
clearly that they only studied the first
three years of use of cordless phones
this is only H mentioned in a footnote
below the table which is uh quite
strange I asked uh Maria F if she could
send me a copy of the questionnaire that
they used in the seal
study she
refused and then I turned to the ethical
board because I know that the ethical
board at the kolinska has to accept the
study uh design including the
questionnaire and I received the
questionnaire a draft questionnaire of
the seph from the ethical board and it
appeared that I didn't include the
strange restriction of the usage of
cordless phones to only the first 3
years the child used
it this study is clearly manipulated you
you you can't imagine any serious
scientist asking uh for only the first
three years of
use both the seph and the inone study
that they show increased risks of brain
tumors for mobile phone users both
children and ad s so the results in the
study when you read them they show
something totally different than what is
communicated to the broad
public
we realized that the only sort of um
safe rule here is that money is behind
everything it's always some political or
economical or industrial uh argument
behind the curtains that will drive a
development in certain direction this is
one of the most influential and power
economic powerful Industries in the
world today and it's not only about the
Telecommunications industry it's also
about the uh defense and Military
industry they also produce microwaves
they also use this technology and they
have the the same interestes this is a
military area move away from the
perimeter I say again this is a military
area move away from the
perimeter this industry gives the most
to governments than any other industry
on the planet it can help the government
secret
services
[Music]
you have to make up your own mind
because nowadays uh all these scientific
areas are heavily Infested by uh other
arguments coming from politics economy
industry and so
forth so don't trust us Trust
[Applause]
[Music]
yourself
for
if the precautionary principle would be
implemented in this particular field
most of these gadgets would immediately
be
forbidden
and in this situation of scientific
uncertainty it's now the national
governments and their institutions that
are responsible for the asan protection
uh who have to decide of uh what to do
in this time period of scientific
uncertainty
as long as this health um issue is off
the agenda it's very difficult indeed uh
to get any serious action taken by the
courts the courts really are not
interested because they say the
international commission and
non-ionizing radiation protection says
there's not a
problem it sounds a very good name the
international Commission of
nonionizing radiation protection sounds
great and you think that's very
important but nobody knows how it's
elect how you're elected to it there are
no changes apparent changes to its
membership I have a very good suggestion
for I would abolish it and uh I I think
it should be it people should be that
are on it should be accountable they
should be elected and should come from
different sources it should not just be
a self-perpetuating group which it is at
present uh and I know I've I've met with
many of them at stages I have a lot of
respect for them but it's there is no
patency and there is no even itself uh
the chairman of of e pich has said well
you know we are not we shouldn't be
regarded totally as just the only
guideline but they are regarded as the
only guideline I consider that those
experts that are lying to the public or
and to the decision makers about what
about what the science has
shown uh of course they should be held
responsible for for for those lies that
that they have produced during years I
think European action is is is perhaps
the best line to take on this I think
for an individual government to go for
it is more difficult but uh in the
meantime I think if if companies or if
areas are unhappy about mask going into
a place or schools are unhappy in terms
of the use of WiFi then I think there
should be some attention paid to these
concerns
[Music]
for
EX
[Music]
[Applause]
J toy
[Music]
Americans are dying my own husband has a
malignant Goma Tower yeah out of the
middle of the
road well my advice to everybody is to
investigate for themselves to check the
evidence and to check the facts about
the the dangers of this radiation and to
try to reduce as much their own
[Applause]
exposure
it's up to all humans to together in
concert try to solve all these issues
they should uh go and find all the
scientific results themselves they are
readily available on the Internet it's
very very easy to find them some experts
say they're seeing evidence of breast
cancer that could be connected to where
some women keep their mobile phones when
you take something that and put it
directly on the skin it's high energy a
microwave radiation for a prolonged
period of time and young women with
vulnerable developing breasts we may
have a perfect storm the the the actual
insert that people never read frankly
that comes with the with the phone it
does say exactly that there's the
Blackberry for example warrants to keep
your phone at least .98 in away from the
body when transmitting if you move it
closer to your head they say they can no
longer guarantee that your phone isn't
emitting more radiation than the FCC
limit for every millimeter away from the
brain you get a 15% reduction in
radiation to the body they should read
they should think they should extract
the necessary information they should
mold it together to a decision boiling
down to their own private
[Music]
[Applause]
person
anas no is Sal
[Applause]
see
forar
spee
for
Electro
sens
GR
for
the first recognition of Electro hypers
sensitivity in Sweden was in
2000 these people with Electro
hypersensitivity H started to get
governmental money governmental funds to
run their different organizations and so
forth
hello
okay
[Music]
for
for this particular group has been
extremely badly treated and they have
been neglected and still are in most
countries and at many times they have
been really
harassed
Des close to 50 % will have one or the
other type of
sensibility within the next 5 10 years
so we will see if
we get over 50% sensitive then we can
start doing
[Music]
something
for
[Music]
foreign
spee
it's been years since uh the cancer
classification and it's a great
deception that there has been no uh
steps towards authorities or mobile
phone industry recommending people to
take uh precautionary measures to handle
this radiation instead nothing has been
done business goes on as you usual
people are not warned about the cancer
risks children are increasingly using
this
technology uh I think it's a completely
Health disaster going on and people are
not informed about the risks mobile
phones computers computer screens and so
on from a biological point of view they
are just toys they are not life
necessities and to have that kind of
very harsh arguments and threats and
discussions about toys uh that's for me
a warning sign really and if you look
around in the world today you do realize
that the needs are very very different
and the needs today is about clean water
clean air food that we can eat without
risk it's about love compassion
understanding respect and uh they are
very seldom actually on this economic
agenda primary word is growth we should
have more and more and more and more of
everything you know and uh that's from a
biological point of view very odd and
[Music]
scary
my advice to those interested in this is
simply don't use your phone too much I I
am I have a mobile phone myself and I'm
using it
most to take pictures because it's a
good
[Music]
camera
if one wants to be really safe then one
has to go back to Natural background
levels uh which were around like for 10
20 30 40 50 years ago you can have
solutions that are not dependent on
radiation and maybe in the future future
if you come back in a 100 years time uh
then we will have a completely other
Society where the progress has meant
stepping
backwards and stepping backwards for
life this industry is considered to be
so important to society and to the
economy that we will have to have a lot
of
victims a lot of dead bodies on the
table and till we take steps to reduce
the risks and the
[Music]
exposure